there are a few sites more hopeful than
this
just a little tiny break week one of the
covid vaccine rollout at the royal
hospital chelsea
a 98 year old d-day veteran lance
corporal bob sullivan
is first in line it's affected me the
same as
everyone else and um
obviously i can't see my family who
most of them live up at windsor
which is not all that far away but so
regardless they
can get here but uh you cannot see me
you miss them
[Music]
hold on maybe there'll be a christmas of
sorts here but they won't forget the 12
chelsea pensioners who lost their lives
to covid have we succeeded
most are receiving their first job today
but beyond these walls there's a debate
started by the former prime minister
tony blair about whether more people
should be given just one
not two doses of the vaccine they could
certainly see immunity building up after
the first dose
but what we don't know is what that
level of immunity would be if you only
gave one dose over the longer term
because those data are not available
from that trial you would need
to have a new research that followed up
those people and looked at what the full
immunity over the longer term was just
from a single dose
i'm just going to be squeezing your arm
okay the governments say they're working
hard on the biggest vaccine rollout in
the nhs's history
around half a million have had their
first jab but there are questions about
the pace of the rollout
we were supposed to have four million
doses by the end of the year
it's still unclear how many are in the
country and there's frustration among
some gps who don't yet have the vaccine
i understand the frustration of
colleagues of you know they are putting
a huge amount of work
into getting their vaccine sites up and
ready uh contacting
eligible patients and this is
particularly elderly patients of you
know in their eighties nineties even
centennial and soviets and those in her
hundreds uh coming to vaccination
centers
uh but doing that at really short notice
and that's because of the logistical
challenges with this particular vaccine
once it's defrosted
it has to be used within three and a
half days we are still
at the very beginning of the vaccine
rollout there are enormous challenges
but for bob at least it is the beginning
of the end
ali ford scoop sky news